so can you tell me a little bit about
your
personal history with video nasties in
that era of uh
cultural provocation of course
um well so i i was born in 1982
so my experience growing up uh
you know a video nasties was it was
quite different to
to enid's experience obviously because i
was a kid
but the the first time i remember
becoming
aware of censorship was probably um
more in the in the early 90s and we'd
been to the video shop and we'd rented
a film me and my mum and i was always
wanting to watch
stuff that was beyond my age range
um and my mom was like making dinner in
the kitchen i put this film on
and this man came up on screen you know
to introduce the film
behind a desk with these kind of the
suits and these
glasses on and he said this film
is a 12 or a 13 i can't remember and
uh it is an offense for anyone under the
age of 12 to watch this movie and i was
probably about eight or something and i
completely freaked out thinking that
my mum was gonna be arrested for letting
me watch this film
ran into the kitchen i was like mom i
can't watch i can't watch it they're
gonna come you're gonna get into trouble
and she said to me it was fine i could
watch the movie i won't get into trouble
um if i wanted to and i watched the film
and the film didn't scare me
because you remember what the film was
it was the lady in white it was spooky
i've seen that yeah that is spooky it's
a spooky film
but i enjoyed the fear because i knew it
wasn't real
you know i was in a safe place to be
scared
whereas this guy at the beginning of the
film with his glasses in this suit was
very real and that was terrifying
so even as a kid i understood the
difference between
fiction and reality you know meanwhile
unbeknownst to me
society you know in the 80s
uh was mixing these things up um
but so i grew up kind of with only
access to certain films like the evil
dead and the texas chainsaw massacre
suspiria the ones that were better known
and then it was more when i moved to
london um and kind of met
you know people who could give me dodgy
copies of
of other films or started going to
horror festivals that i was
able to see some of the lesser known or
you know less obvious films basically
yeah
um what do you think kind of evolved or
changed or adapted
from your short film about this kind of
subject matter
uh nasty to this feature film sensor
um so i had the idea for sensor before
making nasty
um nasty was like almost like
an offshoot of sensor in in that while i
was
researching sensor obviously i was
reading a lot about
the fear around children at this period
and how
you know vhs the invention of vhs now
meaning that these films could go direct
to the home meant that kids could get
their hands on them and what were these
films going to do to
the young generation were we spawning
the next
generation psychopath and i wanted to
explore that idea so i almost
thought of nasty as being like a story
that could be happening on the other
side of town
while enid's having her journey um
but through making the short i i guess i
got to explore
some of the ideas both technical and
narrative ideas uh for censor so that
that kind of fed back into the feature
film
um so that was kind of
yeah the order of things i don't know if
i answered your question or not but
i think you did definitely um and so for
sensor uh in your research in your
research process which i understand
involves speaking to
female film sensors of that era what
were some of the more
surprising or interesting things you
learned through that process
i think one of the first the things that
one of the things that
most surprises um people
is i spoke to one woman called carol
tapolsky
and one of the first things i asked her
was how she felt about horror
and she said how much she loved horror
films and how important they were
as a cathartic experience
for people and this expression of
something darker
you know that's that's important to
create
and watch and and that that i guess
isn't what you expect a film censor to
say
um and and she's also a psychologist so
i think that
you know that probably comes into things
for her
as well but so there was that but i
think one of the things that was really
useful
talking to there was another woman i
spoke to who really didn't like horror
and um i asked her about the kind of
space that they were working in and what
that was like and she said that
um the rooms were really
uh small and there were no windows and
it was dark and so she's indoors
all day during daylight watching films
and sometimes she felt like she was
watching soft porn
you know the stuff that was coming
through and she said she'd
leave work at night and it'd be dark and
she just felt really seedy
and i i really loved that description
and it really
influenced the way i wanted way i
approached
i guess the production design and you
know the
talking to my director of photography
about the look of the
film and particularly in the census
office where you know there's no windows
you've got
windows in the main office but they're
like small windows
like they're in underground um i want it
i imagined it being like a rabbit warren
where down the kind of uh corridors you
can just hear the
screams of people being murdered in
other other horror films
this kind of really oppressive place
where it's just
enid and the horror that she has to look
at every day
so there was so much useful stuff but
they were two of the things that stood
out from speaking with them
and speaking of the craft of the film um
so much of the joy of watching it for me
came from the way it
borrows the language and the grammar of
these video nasties this low budget
exploitation era of horror filmmaking
what are some of the kind of
stylistic homages you pulled off that
you're like the most proud of
like the deepest cut that you're like i
have to put this in
it's funny because you're kind of
leaning into these
tropes um like one of the things i love
about horror is that
um horror fans know horror so well
like horror fans know the language of
horror and so
within horror you can almost create a
new language where you're referencing
and
winking and nodding at other things and
and
that was a lot of fun to play with i
guess it's hard to say like
if there was a thing that was the most
satisfying or
i mean each of the video nasties
the films within the film are like
a nod to different video nazis so
you know i'm referencing um for example
in asunder which was
probably my favorite film within the
film to shoot
um i'm like referencing faulty
a lot in that in that one but also
it always makes me laugh when tom the
male character in the scene says it's
latin
i can work it out because there's always
like
why in horror films is it that there's
always latin scribe
and there's always a character who can
speak latin it always makes me laugh
so it was fun being able to just um
layer in some of those things that i
love about horror and that kind of
make me laugh anyway whether they make
anyone else
um when i spoke to neve earlier she
mentioned specifically
cannibal holocaust as being kind of
maybe a less
fun point of reference for a certain
sequence in the film
i was wondering if you could speak to
that and unpack how that
film and some of those sequences helped
the two of you create this together
yeah um i think it was important for me
to um communicate to the
actors um the gravity
of the censor's role obviously now we
can look back on some of these films and
say oh well
the effects look dated to us now
so obviously it's not real how could
they have
thought this was you know real
or going to do any harm to people and so
when i rehearsed with
neve and nick burns who plays sanderson
one of the first things i did was
i made them watch the turtle scene from
cannibal holocaust which
really really upsets me i mean the
thing with me is violence towards
animals is just
it yeah i can't really deal with it and
so
i know how much that affects me so i
wanted them to
sit and look at this scene and really
connect with the idea that
these people didn't know what they were
about to watch and those films could
have anything in them
because they needed to um sit with the
serious side of that role as well
you know and kind of connect with
that aspect of the job um so
that's how i was using things like
cannibal holocaust
that makes sense um and moving away from
the kind of the referential medal which
we can get as horror filmmakers
especially with a film that's explicitly
about horror films
was it ever difficult to kind of
write your own filmmaking language on
this film to kind of assert your own
directorial identity or was that
something you weren't really concerned
with
um i think you just have your own
directorial identity as a filmmaker
i think that's something you develop as
a filmmaker
through all all of the work you do and
the choices you make um
for me i was nodding towards these films
but ultimately
it's enid's journey and you therefore
have a very
specific point of view as a filmmaker
which
makes it um your film
even if you're referencing faulty or
you're nodding towards argento
um which makes sense because it's a film
about
films from that period um ultimately the
choices you're making are about
keeping the audience with your character
and in their point of view
so you know for example in asunder
i might have you know there could have
been a version of
that that scene where it was a little
bit more hammy and a little bit
um more silly but that would pull the
audience out of
enid's experience watching that film so
you're constantly
trying to just see through enid's eyes
um and i think that's where
you have your unique point of view you
know as a director
so yeah i don't it's funny because i get
asked about this kind of thing a lot and
i
i don't i didn't really overthink it you
know
you're creating and you're you're making
your own choices as a filmmaker so
yeah it's just kind of naturally
inherent to your process i would imagine
yeah
um speaking of enid's journey and seeing
it through her eyes
you know speaking lightly so as to avoid
spoilers
the third act really bends
what is quote unquote true or real
and what is a film and what is
psychology and all of this kind of stuff
did you and neve talk about or craft
like a road map of quote unquote what is
real
in this final sequence or were you kind
of less concerned with what is real
what was sort of the compass of that
sequence
um i think yeah you're always
with with neve i was always talking
about what enid believes
and she has to be playing that and
really what any other character believes
to
to need is not important because she
just needs to play ina's point of view
i think you know what's interesting is
when you have other
characters in scenes who
aren't meaning the same truth as what
enid is
is uh hearing um and that was always
like an interesting balance you know in
both writing and directing the scenes
you know you're playing you're asking
the actors to play
um for their own truth but also then you
need it to be played for enid's truth as
well so you're really playing with that
on set
um and then and then building that in
the edit basically in terms of how you
kind of craft the scene
um but i think we all invested in enid's
version of this story
like every person making the film
became slowly more and more obsessed
with
enid um because the whole film is just
built around
that character and everything is through
her eyes
um so i don't think we really
kind of yeah i don't think we went into
like too much much of what what's real
or what's
not real in that sense because if it's
true to enid then it's true to the film
because
you're in her world you're in her
experience so
that makes sense um i think i have time
for one more question with you
um and i'm curious given the subject
matter of this film
what was the process like for you
getting this film
raided either by the mpaa or the bbfc
were there any kind of backs and forths
what was it like for you well actually
this that's something that's handled by
the distributor so as far as i know
it's um it's an interesting one because
i don't know so much about what's gone
on
over in the states but um the bbfc
have been really supportive of the film
um
right from our research i mean i was
going into the bbfc and
and doing research when we were writing
the film
um but then since then they invited me
on their podcast so at some point i'm
gonna go on and have a chat with them
and i'm really excited to you know when
you're representing
somebody's work even if it's a fictional
version of that
it will be very intriguing to hear how
they feel
um you know it represents what they do
and also there's this added like weird
meta
thing in my head where i'm like imagine
watching the sensors sensor sensor
um that would be a really cool kind of
behind the scenes
video but i i don't think they let that
kind of thing happen
it would be nice if they did on this
occasion
we'll get people to uh start getting you
know release the bailey bond cut
of cutting sensor trending we'll get
that we'll get that on there
cool that sounds great awesome thanks so
much for your time it's great chatting
with you
yes pleasure thanks greg